question
um do you date interracially because you
weren't here when we're asking it
do i when you say date is a date to
marry or just sleep with
yeah
serious things are different because if
i'm dating to marry i probably wouldn't
but if i'm asleep i sleep with i'm an
international citizen
wow this is all black men before they
marry
oh
expand on that no i'm just saying
exactly what he said that they will you
know test the waters everywhere and then
i'll be black love when it's time to
settle down sharing is caring you sound
like you've got a problem with that
though i don't have a problem with it
that's when the hands come out
no i don't have a problem with bitcoin
yeah
so you would sell you were saying you
would have sex with but not settle down
with
i can't say never but um i'd say ideally
i'd settle down with someone who was
either black or mixed race okay india
that i wouldn't say that i'm completely
adverse to
the um sitting down with someone outside
of my race
okay and then is that like a cultural
thing like you just think it's easier
when they have the same culture yeah i
just think yeah yeah well um
with a lot of problems
well fundamentally i think that um
human civilization isn't far gone
enough to accept into relation into
interracial relationships what they are
so i think people who enter them now are
that marks for the cause because with
all the with the high intentions around
race relations and stuff like that
it just makes it a lot more difficult i
don't think it's a bad thing um it's
necessary um but i just think it's just
it's difficult right now as as when
we're just not there yet as a
civilization have you been in an
interracial relationship where that
happened
where what was it like that you said
um like it just seems like you're insane
there's like discrimination again yeah
yeah i i did a whack yo where um her
parents were 100 racist oh okay 100
racist but for me again it's like i'm
i'm quite a traditional african man so
like
unless you're willing to wholeheartedly
accept my culture for what it is and
that means
take time to learn and and dive into
that culture we're going to come into a
crossroads so
i was looking at this and thinking like
what percentage of interracial
relationships in comparison to
same um race relationships kind of lost
and i think it was like 41 of
interracial relationships last up up to
about 10 years and then then the divorce
and then with same-sex with same races
like 31
so i just think to myself you know if i
want an easy life um or an easier life
part of that is culture because we need
to understand each other on a
fundamental level and one of the the
main reasons for why interrelate
interracial relationships broke down was
due to external prejudice and a lack and
a breakdown of communication about their
troubles on the inside so
the basic issue is that is external
prejudice and communication so if you if
you take that away then
things should be easier but at the same
time if that's the main problem i think
that's something that can be easily
overcome with self-awareness and
consistent communication
what about you sarah
uh what about me well same question um
would i do like i've only dated black
women okay i've only dated black women
um all of my life so
um
i guess i guess that's my preference i
guess you know it's like but he said he
wouldn't really consider um someone of a
different weight race for long term do
you feel the same way
yeah i can't see myself long term with
anyone
like but a black woman and it's just
it's it's just what i'm used to
you know
what about you
would i date well currently i'm with
someone
over but would i i'd well before i got
into this relationship that's what i
would have ideally wanted but i found
what i've been looking for so
it all goes in the air
okay but your ideal would have been like
a black girl yeah but i'm sure her idea
would have been someone six foot by my
six foot
what about you long term pal
long term yeah
um i don't care like i just don't
care what i just as long as they're
attractive and tall i'd say my long term
is tall
[Laughter]
tall ladies would you
long term
black doesn't matter long term is him
ah
i feel like my deal would be to date
black but as i've gotten older i'm kind
of getting rid of that and trying to
date
outside of my race but i feel like um
i haven't dated many men which are
outside of my race but i've dated women
the outside of my wrist
that's a whole nother caveat just got it
it's a bit it's different or let's say
outside of my culture if that and that
was the first time i was kind of
understanding like
wow how heavily
my culture is a part of me it's not just
like oh you love this person and yada
yada it's just like
what you are saying someone really has
to accept you and see you for who you
are because it's literally in everything
that you do down to literally my tick
tock like my for you page is fully just
of black people and i didn't realize
that in comparison to say like somebody
else's that i was speaking to a date and
dares was not necessarily full of white
people but just like i don't know i
think for some people it's always it's
me and you against the world and i don't
see it that way it's just it's two
families coming together if our families
can't connect and we're never gonna
connect because i always think you're
always going to come into a crossroads
in a relationship and have trouble and
the family needs to be able to bring you
back together but if her mom's like i
told her about that black brother and
then your dad your your dad saying ah
white women they're standing up
it's long yeah it's never gonna work
then you know you know what's
interesting so
i always hear from
from like black girls that like black
guys date out a lot of the time but it's
interesting because the black guys that
i've dated i was always the exception
like it wasn't i wasn't like they didn't
typically date white girls like it was
like mostly black girls why'd you be
nice
i don't know
i don't know there's something about
pearl
[Laughter]
no i don't know it's just interesting
because i always hear that but it's just
not what i've seen like when i talk to
guys like it always seems like their
preference is black girls but then after
you do you broke up did they go with the
white girl did they go to with a black
girl no they went to a black girl next
really
wow that's interesting
i don't yeah that's interesting i don't
okay white guys do tend to experiment
with black girls as well and then just
dip
here's the thing do you think that
you've been that experiment oh
definitely wow oh no
tell us the story
no
no no because so then is that is that
part of the whole
fetishization thing you're just gonna
experiment with someone just to see
is that the whole like
fetish like who wants to be a fetish
i don't think experimenting is
necessarily a fish it's kind of like
like i said with me even just exploring
something that you haven't experienced
before and seeing if it could go
somewhere or not but it's not
necessarily you're fetishizing a person
you're going with them specifically
because they're from this background and
they can offer you this and etc i don't
know i find that when the white guys try
to on a date
well not all the time when they date
white women i mean black women it is
just to be like it's a tick on a box
like i know a girl that went university
with like she's a nigerian girl to me
she's very african but she grew up in a
very she grew up in milton keynes where
she's surrounded by white guys so she's
attracted to black guys but she's never
been approached by black guys because
the area or her surroundings are just
white guys and she will tell me about a
lot of different stories where she went
through one guy she was seeing his phone
he was like yeah me i'm smashing this
black bird and did it and and they're
having these banterous conversations
about him tapping the black chick and
it's like yeah this time over so i
i've had a few this conversation around
university and stuff like that where i
do find that when white guys do engage
in the sexual relations of black women
it's a tick on a box and to say i've
been here not necessarily i want to be
the first black person that they've
dated it's interesting because when i
talk to white guys they just don't care
it's like she's hot i'm down
i was literally about to agree with you
yeah like like because um i have i have
five brothers
and they don't they're like if she's
she's hot she got a booty then i mean
that's the thing is like for me i'm i'm
always more cognizant of that it's like
would you take that girl home i want to
introduce her to your family yeah that's
when you know where it's real she's if
she's hot they wouldn't care i thought
yeah that's a difference
i agree
no sometimes it's just preference that's
the thing maybe that individual hasn't
fought far enough yet because yeah she
might be hot but like i said even with
me sometimes like these girls i would
chop but i would not bring you home
that's just that's just what it is but
i'm cognizant of those things so like
with these guys and again they're taking
a step further and bantering about it so
now they're taking a piss out of her so
like like that's to me that's mad but so
in a in agreeance to what pearl was
saying i found that the average white
guy
if he finds a beautiful
black girl he will take her seriously
wife her give her the world and
everything whereas you'll find the guys
that
what you'd find that are closer to the
20
will do exactly what you're saying
so it depends what kind of bracket
you're in you'll find that the behaviors
are different
potentially yeah
i've heard black women say that black
men will have sex with any white girl
doesn't matter
big small nice you've got to have cheeks
i hate to use this term because but i
heard it on clubhouse the spicy whites
that's why what does that mean no
spicy whites it's yeah i i heard it on
clubhouse like last year it's like the t
it types it tends to be the type of
white women that black men date that's
what spicy whites what does that mean
yeah what does it mean i think like you
know the ones that kind of emanate
black features i mean the ones that you
know go to the r b room when you go to
them
i've never